kyler murray now shereen you mentioned
him last week in the context of the
bengals possibly taking receiver jamar
chase and joe burrows comments about
that which were very diplomatic and not
necessarily over the top go get jamar go
get jamar get my former teammate because
as you pointed out last year kyler
murray was very vocal with his desire
that the team drafts cd lamb
a former calamari college teammate here
is kyla murray from nfl network
explaining that he believes entering
year three of his career that he should
have some sort of a say in what the
cardinals do on draft day here he is
i do believe i think i have an influence
in it um i don't know why i wouldn't you
know i think you know if you got a guy a
quarterback and you trust him and you
you know you want to be the face of the
franchise for you know a lot of years i
think
he should have influence just because i
mean everything you know is technically
built around the quarterback so
um i think i had that relationship with
uh steve and cliff and um you know i'm
excited to see what we do on thursday
look
this is a debate that comes up in
various contexts with various
quarterbacks and some would say
you just play football you're not
involved in management remember the
story that came out this year from the
athletic about russell wilson trying to
have a voice in fixing the offense when
it was struggling they had a short week
coming up coincidentally against the
arizona cardinals he had ideas for
fixing the offense
seahawks said thank you no thank you
shireen i'm a firm believer
that
if you expect your starting quarterback
to be
basically
a manager
working among the other employees which
is what a true
leader is going to do show up early stay
late study the playbook hold guys
accountable set the right example
be the emissary for management
management tells the quarterback what it
wants the players to do and the
quarterback ends up being the one who
communicates the message and keeps
everyone in line ideally that's how it
works if you're going to expect that out
of your quarterback
you can't freeze him out you just can't
you can't tell him sit down shut up you
just work here so
i don't know that influence is the right
answer but i definitely think they
should hear him out i think it's smart
to hear out your key players you guys
who you're building the team around and
with quarterbacks becoming more and more
important every year yeah if you've got
a guy that you're going to value for
years into the future why do you not
want to make him a partner in the way
that you're running your football team
because he's the one who's going to be
expected to inspire that guy along with
everyone else to elevate the team above
the sum of the individual parts that's
what a great quarterback can do so i
think you empower your quarterback to
have a voice and if you disagree with
what he's saying
you have the respect for him that he's
going to understand it
and you talk to him like an adult and
you tell him why you're going to go in a
different direction it's not that
complicated
yeah you answered my question mike and i
was going to ask if conor murray had
earned that one pro bowl that frankly
should have gone to tom brady last
season no playoff appearances but you
answered it because yes they do value
him as their franchise quarterback
that's how they see him as their
franchise quarterback i always say this
i would think he would have more say if
they're looking on the off offensive
side of the ball i just remember troy
aikman going and working out prospects
one year throwing with attack which
couldn't do that this year but throwing
with the tight ends and the receivers
and players that they were interested in
i know he did that and so then they got
his feedback and and that's perfectly
acceptable if if something like that
happens and you know kyle murray was in
college recently and so he knows many of
these college players he played against
them so he can give you feedback so i
don't think it hurts to get that
feedback but do i want him making my
pick probably not but i would take his
feedback and listen to him and maybe he
makes a good point on this thing but i
tell you what mike this is another team
that better go defense considering how
they ranked offensively last season and
how they ranked defensively or 13th in
total defense last year they've got to
improve that defense again if they're
going to contend especially in the
hardest division in football
hey you know let me take it a step
farther shireen because if i had a young
quarterback that i envisioned being the
centerpiece of the franchise for years
to come and i think it's fair to call
kyler murray that i would find ways if
he's a guy who lives in town all year
long is around now i know they're
limited in what they can do by way of
meeting with players in the off-season
but i would find a way
to get him involved
as involved as i possibly can with free
agency preparations with draft
preparations teach him how to evaluate
personnel who better as he grows and
matures and develops as a player than
the quarterback to understand
how they go about looking for talent
what they go about looking for teach him
the language teach him that skill
think of the way that quarterbacks and
and look at the guys like john elway who
became a great executive in denver
despite having
very limited experience and i had
concerns about him getting that job when
he did because it's not like anybody
else was trying to hire him it was a
denver thing but when you have been that
great leader on the field you could
develop into a great leader they could
be grooming a great gm for another team
frankly but i i think that if you've got
a guy who's all in and you've got the
quiet months where you know he's working
out on his own and he's doing things i
and he wants to do it if he wants to do
it if he wants to learn if he loves it
that much i just think that there's a
lot of value there in having one of your
key players fully understand what you're
looking for all in in the planning
process all in in the scouting process
that could be a very valuable tool that
teams aren't taking advantage of
and there's certain quarterbacks in the
league mike that i absolutely would
listen to their opinions that's tom
brady and russell wilson and uh aaron
rodgers and those guys we know uh out
there who who you definitely would
listen to to what they want and what
they think and and they look at these i
guarantee tom brady looks at these
players and probably gives them feedback
on who he wants we saw it in free agency
a lot we saw it last year a lot so
yeah if they want to give kyle murray
some of those powers and he wants to
learn how to do it how to watch film
correctly and and figure out who they
might draft
go for it and and do a good job at it
and they can listen to them and they
don't have to take what he says and and
make that their draft pick because it's
their jobs on the line not necessarily
kyla murray's job on the line so they
need to make those picks for who they
think the best player is not who caller
murray says the best player is but they
can have a good discussion about it for
sure mike especially on the offensive
side of the ball
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports